- Il y a 12 000 ans,
l'homme prend un tournant décisif.
Quittant sa vie nomade,
il s'installe dans des villages.
Il invente l'agriculture,
l'élevage, l'irrigation,
le commerce, les alliages,
les religions, l'architecture,
la médecine...
De nombreuses épreuves
l'attendent :
la propriété engendre
les 1res guerres,
le bétail provoque des épidémies,
la surpopulation, des famines.
Mais Homo sapiens continue.
Il construit des cités
et imagine une société complexe,
organisée, hiérarchisée.
Il communique à grande distance
grâce à l'écriture.
En 8 000 ans,
|a population de la planète
passe de 3 à 100 millions
d'habitants.
Il bâtit la société
qui est la nôtre.
Il n'est plus le même qu'avant.
Il est l'homme contemporain :
nous.
Voici les grands moments
qui ont conduit
à notre naissance.
un.
L'histoire de notre évolution
en homme contemporain
commence il y a environ 15 000 ans
par un grand changement climatique
rapide :
la planète se réchauffe, provoquant
d'immenses changements.
En quelques siècles, la calotte
glaciaire fond des 2 tiers.
Des morceaux de banquise
se détachent,
les océans remontent de 120 mètres.
C'est la grande débâcle.
Les contours de la Terre deviennent
ceux d'aujourd'hui.
Dans certaines zones,
des pluies diluviennes
provoquent d'énormes inondations.
Dans d'autres,
l'aridification s'accentue,
et des incendies naturels
embrasent les forêts.
L'âge de glace est terminé.
Les hommes "inventent"
les temps modernes.
Une partie de la Terre
se désertifie.
Des pionniers vont naître
dans le "Croissant fertile" :
le Proche-Orient d'aujourd'hui.
Nous sommes il y a 12 000 ans.
4 millions d'hommes et de femmes
habitent la planète.
Ils sont nomades. Ils vivent
dans des espaces immenses
et croisent rarement
d'autres êtres humains.
Notre clan a domestiqué les loups.
On en a fait des chiens.
Leur adresse m'aide
à nourrir le clan.
J'en ai fait des membres
de notre famille.
Ça ne plaît pas
à tout le monde.
Ils parlent dans leur langue.
un.
- Je suis Aar, le protecteur.
On m'écoute,
car je suis le plus fort. Tous ici
ont placé leur destin
entre mes mains.
Assha est ma 2e compagne.
Elle attend son 1er enfant.
un.
- Pour la naissance,
je veux trouver un endroit clément
où l'eau est abondante.
Nous croyons en Gaya,
la mère éternelle,
cette nature féminine qui prodigue
ce dont on a besoin.
Les pères de mes pères ont tous
porté cette amulette.
Gaya nous protégera
pendant le voyage.
Depuis le changement climatique,
les paysages ont changé.
Par endroits,
la nature est généreuse.
L'eau a imprégné le sol.
Les collines ont verdi.
Les céréales sauvages ont poussé.
Et les animaux faciles à chasser
se sont multipliés.
La survie des hommes
est plus simple.
Les chiens aboient.
- Un autre grand changement
vient de se produire.
Une idée étrange vient d'éclore
et elle va surprendre
tout le monde.
Des tipis de pierres!
Avec une chevelure de feuilles
à leur sommet.
Nous n'avions jamais vu ça.
L'endroit idéal
pour notre campement.
- On ignorait que c'était
ce qu'on appelle des maisons.
Un autre mode de vie
avait été découvert,
une invention qui va bouleverser
la vie des hommes.
Ils appellent.
- Des humains avaient décidé
de s'installer ici,
d'arrêter de marcher,
pour rayonner autour d'un centre:
leur village.
Mais où étaient-ils ?
un.
Ce qui nous a surpris,
ce sont les sacs de pierre.
Ils conservaient l'eau
et la nourriture.
On n'avait pas idée
de faire des récipients si lourds.
Quel intérêt avait un abri
impossible à déplacer?
Ils avaient mis un arbre
dans leurs tipis.
Ces hommes faisaient
comme les araignées.
un.
- Chaud dehors et frais dedans.
La température était agréable,
l'odeur aussi.
Une odeur d'hommes, de femmes
et d'enfants,
et l'arôme
de la viande séchée.
De la nourriture,
il y en avait beaucoup.
Pour survivre sans bouger,
il faut
prévoir
quand la nature ne donne plus.
Les sédentaires ne sont pas encore
agriculteurs.
Ils cueillent.
Ils ignorent encore
qu'on peut cultiver.
un.
- Ils ajoutent une facette
au genre humain,
une facette
que les nomades ignorent:
le sens de la propriété.
Pour nous, les richesses
sont à tout le monde.
Les sédentaires ne peuvent plus
penser ainsi.
Sans réserves,
ils ne peuvent survivre.
Alors naît ce sentiment étrange :
la crainte
de se faire ravir ses richesses.
un.
- Pour le nomade, l'étranger
est un voyageur comme lui.
Même quand les denrées sont rares,
on doit partager pour survivre.
un.
- Chez l'homme sédentaire,
étranger veut dire danger.
Il était prêt a défendre
sa propriété comme sa propre vie.
Des chiens aboient.
Une voix appelle.
- Nous étions entrés ici
comme partout,
comme chez nous. Mais
ça a été pris pour une agression.
Ce sentiment bizarre semblait
s'être emparé de tout.
Leurs maisons étaient a eux,
leurs sacs de pierre et même l'eau.
On ne comprenait pas
leur agressivité.
Pour nous, rencontrer un humain
est une chance.
On lui doit l'hospitalité.
Et, plus extraordinaire,
ils considéraient
que la terre
était leur propriété.
Cette terre sur laquelle
nos ancêtres avaient vécu,
ils voulaient
que personne n'y entre.
Ils nous chassaient comme
des guêpes autour de leur repas.
un.
- Nous sommes venus en paix.
Il y a une femme enceinte.
L'endroit nous convient.
On restera malgré vos menaces.
Se sédentariser. Comment les hommes
ont-ils eu cette drôle d'idée ?
Il se peut que les céréales
aient joué un rôle.
Il faut broyer les grains
en farine.
Pour cela,
il faut 2 pierres si lourdes
qu'elles sont impossibles
à transporter dans une vie nomade.
Alors les hommes sont restés
près des grosses pierres,
et ça a considérablement changé
leur comportement.
A la fin de la journée, le nomade
regarde la nature s'endormir,
alors que le sédentaire
compte ses réserves.
Mais |a vie nomade comporte
de nombreux aléas.
Les femmes enceintes
sont bien placées pour le savoir.
On a rarement de longues réserves.
Et quand la nature n'est plus
généreuse, on souffre du manque.
un.
- Assha ne peut plus digérer
cette purée de fruits.
Elle a besoin de viande,
elle a besoin de forces.
La viande séchée est épuisée.
Dès qu'il y a un problème,
c'est Aka qui vient
siffler dans mes oreilles.
Les autres, ils n'osent pas.
un.
- Trop tard pour chasser. Et toutes
ces provisions si proches.
Je décide de me servir
dans leurs réserves.
Pas par vengeance, ni convoitise.
J'ai pris ce qu'il me fallait.
Ils vivaient entourés
des outils qui leur servaient
à préparer cet étrange grain
dont ils avaient fait
le cœur de leur subsistance.
Chez les nomades,
la cellule sociale est le groupe.
Avec la vie sédentaire apparaît
une nouvelle unité : la famille.
Chaque famille a son espace:
sa maison.
L'inconvénient,
c'est que des petits animaux
en veulent à leurs provisions.
Les sédentaires continuent
à prélever
tout ce qu'ils peuvent manger.
Un chien aboie.
- Certains n'ont pas domestiqué
le chien.
Il l'a été
en Europe de l'ouest et en Chine.
Il servait pour la chasse,
la garde, l'élimination des déchets,
la compagnie.
L'homme et l'animal
y avaient trouvé intérêt.
un.
- Le sédentaire comprendra vite
l'intérêt de l'animal.
un.
- Ne touche pas. C'est pas pour toi.
Le vieux ne pensait
qu'à son ventre.
Assha s'affaiblissait.
J'ignorais comment lui redonner
des forces.
Un chien aboie.
- Ce soir-là, on est soudain devenus
fréquentables.
La veille, on ne pouvait
même pas boire leur eau.
un.
Ils donnaient
leurs sacs de pierre
et ces grains qui piquent.
Ce n'était pas un présent.
Ils s'attendaient
à ce qu'on leur offre un chien.
Je ne voulais pas de ça,
ni me séparer d'un chien.
Ils ont voulu me confier le secret
des grains qui piquent la langue.
Assha a senti un danger.
Peut être que ce jour-là,
j'aurais dû suivre son instinct.
Nous étions trop différents
de ces gens-là.
Le drame aurait pu être évité.
C'était mou et sans goût.
Ça ne me plaisait pas.
J'aurais préféré ces souris
que mon chien trouvait.
Le ventre se remplissait vite,
et pour la borgne,
édentée,
c'était plus facile à manger
que la viande.
Le sédentaire avait compris
que le chien lui serait utile.
Pour l'avoir, il voulait me donner
ses objets, mais c'était une ruse.
Ses cadeaux ne venaient pas
du cœur.
Garde tes objets.
Moi, je garde le chien.
Le sédentaire accumule des biens.
Posséder devient un objectif,
et on pense tout obtenir
grâce aux richesses accumulées.
Le nomade ne comprend pas cela.
La vie des nomades est faite
d'épreuves et d'imprévus.
La nature et ses forces dominent
leur existence.
Leurs croyances sont liées
à ces forces inexplicables.
un.
Les sédentaires continuent
à redouter la nature,
mais leur organisation
les affranchit de ses excès,
et rend la vie
plus prévisible.
Le tipi de pierre ne vacille pas
sous le vent
et ne craint pas
les aboiements du feu.
Le tipi de peau ne résiste pas
aux tornades
et encore moins a |a puissance
dévastatrice des flammes.
un.
Un nomade est prêt à tout perdre
du jour au lendemain.
Ce qui était hier
ne sera peut-être plus demain.
Cette incertitude est précisément
ce que le sédentaire va combattre.
un.
- Le sédentaire cherche toujours
à éviter |es surprises.
Ils nous proposaient
de les rejoindre.
Partir ou rester un peu avec eux ?
Si on partait, Assha serait
sans abri pendant |a délivrance.
Face au chaos de la vie,
le sédentaire
propose une solution rassurante,
stable.
Même si les nomades préfèrent
une vie aventureuse à une vie
faite de travail et de routine,
la sécurité a un pouvoir
de séduction énorme.
Pour nous, les villageois
ont libéré un de leurs tipis.
Mais quand on a toujours dormi
sous des peaux,
on ne dort pas bien
dans cet espace
où même les voix
ont du mal à s'échapper.
Aka s'est vite habituée
aux galettes de pain,
mais Assha, épuisée,
ne peut plus manger.
Aka comprend qu'elle peut
la nourrir en lui mâchant le pain.
Dans ce monde de pierre,
on manque d'air pour respirer,
on manque de brise
pour se rafraîchir...
Je préfère dormir
sous les étoiles.
Le nomade sait lutter
contre la nature,
survivre
dans des conditions extrêmes.
Il s'adapte à l'environnement.
Pour devenir sédentaire,
il lui faudra changer.
Beaucoup réussiront. D'autres non.
Le sédentaire adapte
son environnement à ses besoins.
Quelques jours ont passé.
Nous avons essayé de nous habituer.
Les villageois ont feint
d'être contents,
et puis une vraie complicité
est née.
Ourham aurait mon chien quand
les poules auraient des dents.
Mais on n'avait pas
encore inventé la poule...
Une petite fille était née
du ventre de Assha.
Mais Assha, comme la 1re compagne
de Aar, n'avait pas survécu.
Son souffle n'était plus.
Elle était partie rejoindre
les nôtres dans la mer des étoiles.
Une fille de Gaya était partie,
une autre était venue.
Sans personne pour la nourrir.
Le bébé pleure.
- Il se peut qu'alors, l'homme
n'ait pas |a conscience d'être père
et que les enfants sont aussi
une partie d'eux-mêmes.
Les nomades accompagnent
les morts dans un autre monde,
puis ils reprennent leur chemin et
ne gardent des leurs qu'un souvenir.
Elle ne pourra survivre
sans mère nourricière.
Le clan ne pouvait nourrir
son dernier enfant.
Qu'allait devenir
la lignée de Gaya ?
Le lendemain, à l'aube,
nous avons repris notre chemin.
J'ai laissé mon meilleur chien
à Ourham,
en récompense de sa générosité :
je lui laissai la fille d'Assha.
La seule solution pour qu'elle vive.
Gaya aussi demeurerait
avec l'enfant,
sa lignée continuerait à vivre
par la fille d'Assha.
La plupart des nomades vont adopter
la vie sédentaire,
pour le confort et la sécurité.
Ils nous laisseront
cette soif de liberté et ce goût
pour la découverte de l'inconnu.
La sédentarité va changer
le comportement humain
et le faire entrer dans une spirale
d'inventions que rien n'arrêtera.
L'agriculture remplacera
la collecte de céréales sauvages.
Le blé et l'orge vont s'étendre
à toute l'Europe et à l'lndus.
Le riz et le millet, en Chine.
Maïs et pommes de terre,
en Amérique.
Le sorgho, en Afrique.
Sapiens opère
les 1res sélections génétiques.
Il choisit les graines
des plantes les plus robustes.
Pour cultiver,
l'homme va ouvrir des clairières.
Les paysages vont s'humaniser.
Nous sommes en 7 500 avant J-C,
au Proche-Orient.
Le hameau est devenu un village.
Plus de sécurité,
plus de stabilité.
Les femmes font plus d'enfants,
qui meurent moins.
Plus de gens, plus de maisons,
plus de tensions aussi.
Les maisons rondes
ont été remplacées
par des rectangulaires,
qu'on peut agrandir
ou découper en pièces autonomes.
Je suis Ouki,
de la dynastie de Gaya.
C'est mon amulette qui le dit.
Elle, c'est Nekee.
et depuis tout jeune, je rêve
de fonder une famille avec elle.
Nous avons une maison des morts.
On y garde les dépouilles
des ancêtres.
Ce lieu nous permet
d'entretenir leur mémoire.
On conserve les crânes
et on les maquille.
Nous savons d'où et de qui nous
sommes issus depuis des générations.
L'importance de nos familles
est liée au nombre de crânes.
Je ne suis pas le seul prétendant
à la belle Nekee.
Oukou, de la famille des Belouta,
est mon rival.
Les Belouta sont une grande
famille du village.
Ils ont
beaucoup d'hommes valeureux.
Mais Oukou était un lâche
qui profitait de son nom.
Ce jour-là s'est produit
une chose...
un.
Le père de Nekee choisirait |'époux
en fonction des intérêts
de sa famille.
La dispute avait créé
une situation périlleuse,
et j'ai réclamé le droit
de demander la main de Nekee.
Nous avions domestiqué
quelques animaux.
Au début,
des petits ramenés de la chasse.
Des marcassins,
des chevreaux des montagnes...
Si on les nourrissait, on avait
une réserve de viande fraîche.
Ces animaux étaient rares,
et j'ai offert notre seul marcassin,
en cadeau d'alliance.
Mais la famille d'0ukou avait offert
2 animaux encore plus rares.
Les chats étaient arrivés dans nos
villages, attirés par les rongeurs.
Ils sont rapidement devenus
des alliés de grande valeur.
Posséder avait une incidence
sur ce qu'on peut faire
ou obtenir des autres.
Et le moins riche devient
moins puissant que le plus riche.
La compétition entre les hommes
change de forme.
La loi du plus fort devient
celle du plus fortuné.
Les relations entre les hommes
et les femmes ont changé.
Une nouvelle forme du désir
est apparue.
Une attraction puissante
qu'on a appelé l'amour.
Une forme de liberté individuelle,
en dehors des règles du groupe,
commence à se faire jour.
On ne veut plus que le désir
soit empêché par les autres.
J'étais amoureux de Nekee. Et Nekee
avait été donnée à un autre.
Mon ventre souffrait,
mon âme aussi.
J'avais beau invoquer
l'esprit de |a forêt,
j'avais contre moi
les règles du village.
Quand on n'est pas d'accord,
quand on ne veut plus la respecter,
on doit s'en aller.
Alors j'ai décidé de le faire.
Mais pas tout seul.
Je défiais les règles du village,
j'offensais Oukou, sa famille
et le père de Nekee.
Pour ces raisons, j'emmenais Nekee
loin, pour fonder une famille...
On avait la vie devant nous,
on était libres et on s'aimait.
Personne n'avait osé faire ça,
avant.
Je crois que ce jour-là,
on a inventé le paradis.
un.
Nekee se refroidissait.
Je la guérirai avec des plantes.
En attendant, il fallait
|a réchauffer. C'était dangereux,
mais je n'avais pas le choix.
Oukou ne voulait pas perdre
son aimée.
Son amour déçu,
le pouvoir des chefs de famille
en faisaient un ennemi coriace,
tenace et sans pitié.
un.
Ils avaient détruit mon corps.
Seul un fragment de souffle
me maintenait en vie.
Je m'accrochai à cet air qui
rentrait et sortait de ma poitrine.
A cette époque.
on sait qu'on peut
enfouir des graines qui donneront
des plantes
en quelques semaines.
On choisit les meilleures,
et on améliore la qualité du grain.
Mon père a vite compris
qu'il s'était passé
quelque chose de grave.
Un conflit entre individus peut
devenir discorde entre familles.
Oukou et les siens voulaient
ma mort.
Notre rivalité allait devenir
le grand drame de notre village.
Mon père et mon frère m'ont cherché
pendant longtemps.
Oukou avait effacé les traces qui
auraient permis de me retrouver.
Des jours ont passé.
Ma vie ne tenait qu'à un fil.
J'ai tenu grâce à ces pousses.
Je les voyais grandir,
quand je reprenais conscience.
Elles étaient la vie,
elles étaient ma lumière.
On sait gérer les conflits
dans sa famille,
mais rarement ceux
entre différentes familles.
Il n'y a pas de lois, de juges,
de sanctions.
La justice n'est pas encore
inventée.
J'étais fini,
par la faute de la famille Belouta.
Leur fils, un mort vivant.
Rien ne pourrait réparer
cette douleur.
Le pouvoir des plantes est connu
depuis longtemps.
La chirurgie apparaît
a cette époque.
On commence à pratiquer
la trépanation,
pour guérir les traumatismes,
la démence,
et autres maladies inexplicables.
Comment régler une dispute
entre deux clans ?
La meilleure manière serait
de partir. Mais ici,
chacun a ses terres, ses maisons
et ne veut pas les abandonner.
Le village est dans une impasse.
Le trou dans mon crâne avait libéré
le sang qui me paralysait.
Je survivrai,
mais comme un parasite.
Je serai incapable d'aider
ma famille dans les champs.
C'était l'année où il n'a pas plu.
La terre ne donnait rien,
et le village se lamentait.
On n'avait pas compris que l'eau
était essentielle aux plantes.
Personne n'avait fait
le rapprochement avec la sécheresse.
Tout le monde a fait
le rapprochement avec moi.
J'avais défié les esprits,
ils nous punissaient.
Même mon père m'en voulait.
J'étais le responsable
de la malédiction.
C'était la 1re fois
que je revoyais Nekee.
Par amour, j'avais tout perdu,
et le plus important:
elle.
Jamais je ne |a reprendrai.
Les esprits m'avaient puni.
J'étais condamné à rester seul.
Je passais mon temps a observer
|a nature, a percer ses secrets.
Mon corps était sans force,
mais mon esprit restait en éveil.
L'idée m'est apparue soudainement.
Une idée peut changer
la vie des hommes
et faire basculer notre destinée.
Ma main
qui creuse un sillon sur le sol.
L'eau qui s'écoule lentement.
Les graines qui germent.
Le vert tendre des jeunes pousses
qui grandissent.
L'eau était le secret de la vie !
Tout était la, devant nos yeux,
mais nous ne l'avions pas compris.
Ainsi fut inventée l'irrigation.
Mon père et mon frère ne m'ont pas
cru, mais ont essayé.
Ils n'ont pas ménagé leur effort.
Pour me faire plaisir.
L'irrigation va donner
une grande force
au système sédentaire.
irriguées, les cultures donneront
beaucoup plus.
Finies les disettes.
L'homme va étendre son système
sédentaire. Les villages pourront
s'installer dans des zones arides
et faire venir l'eau
sur leurs cultures.
J'avais volé au ciel ses pouvoirs.
Je faisais honte a |a pluie.
Mon idée était
plus forte que la nature,
plus forte que tous les esprits.
Oukou est venu espionner
pour comprendre,
alors que ses champs restaient secs.
Il pensait encore
au mauvais sort.
L'irrigation nous a permis
de produire plus de céréales
et de mieux nous nourrir.
Soudain nous avions des surplus,
des excédents de production.
C'est devenu une richesse.
On avait du pouvoir
sur ceux qui manquaient.
L'avantage de cette richesse,
c'est qu'elle peut être échangée.
Le père de Nekee
nous a offert des présents
en échange de notre grain.
Et l'échange apaise les conflits,
car il permet
de renouer un dialogue
et une satisfaction mutuelle.
Nous, de la lignée
de Gaya, étions devenus les plus
puissants, les plus respectés.
Mais la famille d'0ukou...
Je ne voulais pas.
Je n'oubliais pas
ce qu'ils m'avaient fait.
Jamais je ne leur donnerai
un grain de blé.
Ainsi la richesse peut devenir
une forme de violence.
Avec le marcassin refusé par le père
de Nekee, j'avais eu une idée.
En enfermant des mâles et
des femelles, ils se multipliaient.
Cette trouvaille va bientôt
faire le tour du monde.
Je l'aimais encore.
Je n'avais jamais cessé de l'aimer.
J'avais cru qu'elle reviendrait,
puis j'ai cessé d'espérer.
Nekee m'a persuadé.
Je la privais de nourriture
à cause de son mari.
Elle n'y était pour rien.
Alors j'ai pardonné.
L'agriculture, l'élevage,
l'irrigation...
L'homme peut se dire
qu'il manipule le monde vivant
et qu'il a pris le dessus
sur les éléments.
J'étais devenu plus fort
que |es esprits.
Ce pouvoir le rend fier
et dominateur.
Il se croit plus puissant
que la nature.
D'ailleurs,
pour représenter ses divinités,
il abandonne les images
d'animaux.
Il se représente lui-même.
incantations.
un.
-Ouki a même trouvé une femme
et a fondé une famille.
La lignée de Gaya aura
une descendance.
Acclamations et incantations.
- Les échanges de biens
seront relayés
par des échanges de savoir-faire.
Les innovations vont
circuler sur de grandes distances,
et les hommes
vont évoluer plus rapidement.
Après l'agriculture, l'élevage
va se répandre sur la planète.
Après le loup devenu chien,
on domestiquera le mouton
et la chèvre au Proche-Orient.
Le sanglier deviendra le cochon.
L'aurochs deviendra le bœuf.
On domestiquera la poule
au Pakistan, l'âne en Palestine,
le cheval en Europe
et en Asie,
le lama au Pérou,
l'abeille en Égypte.
Cela a favorisé
l'explosion démographique,
mais ça a aussi entraîné
des effets maléfiques.
De terribles épreuves attendent
les hommes.
Nous sommes
en 3 500 avant Jésus-Christ.
Le village s'est encore agrandi.
Plus de mille personnes y vivent.
Des voyageurs ont apporté la roue.
Nos travaux sont facilités.
On a des métiers:
tailleurs de pierre, maçons,
forgerons, potiers...
Tous pratiquent
l'agriculture et l'élevage.
Il y a beaucoup de familles.
Des disputes,
il y en a sans arrêt.
Pour arbitrer,
un conseil rend justice
et prend les grandes décisions
collectives.
Urhu et Waka étaient frères,
de la lignée de Gaya,
une des plus anciennes.
Waka, l'aîné, portait l'amulette
des chefs de famille.
Leurs jugements étaient respectés
de tous.
Chacun avait son champ,
ses bêtes,
son logement. On avait
des biens et leurs problèmes.
Posséder, c'est défendre.
Les chèvres du tanneur ont mangé
dans le champ du potier.
Une partie de sa récolte
était perdue.
Dans ces cas,
on faisait appel au conseil.
Le conseil tranchait,
souvent selon la coutume.
Des échanges de biens réparaient
les offenses.
La décision des sages suffisait
à calmer ces conflits.
Le fragile équilibre du village
reposait sur ces décisions.
Des malheurs
allaient le faire éclater,
avec l'aide d'Urhu et
sa gourmandise pour les richesses.
J'étais Ike, le fils de Waka,
de la lignée de Gaya.
Nous avions des champs
et des chèvres,
mais mon père était surtout
le forgeron du village.
Les 1ers métaux étaient apparus,
et leur pouvoir nous fascinait.
De la montagne,
je ramenai à mon père du minerai
qu'on trouve à l'état naturel,
comme le cuivre ou l'or.
Il en faisait des récipients
et des outils.
Ils étaient trop fragiles
pour retourner la terre.
Depuis peu, la peau de ma mère
s'était teintée de rouge.
Personne ne se doutait alors
de la grande tragédie.
Chaque semaine, on tuait une chèvre
pour se nourrir.
Je n'aimais pas ça. Je ne savais
jamais laquelle choisir.
J'ignorais qu'il y avait
des créatures invisibles
et néfastes.
Le 1er signe de la grande tragédie
fut cette chèvre.
Les microbes, les bactéries,
les virus...
Ces créatures se développaient
à grande vitesse,
grâce a |a concentration d'hommes,
d'animaux et de déjections.
Ma mère était atteinte
d'un mal grandissant.
Après les plaques rouges,
elle fut prise de violentes fièvres
et de vomissements.
Urhu, le frère de mon père,
était guérisseur.
Il maîtrisait
la science des plantes
et faisait des breuvages
et des onguents.
On a toujours eu des maladies,
mais une nouvelle forme mystérieuse
apparaissait, plus dangereuse,
plus dévastatrice.
Urhu se voulait rassurant.
Il tenait à son prestige
et à sa récompense.
Son pouvoir de guérisseur
viendrait à bout du mal.
Urhu adorait les cadeaux.
Il l'aurait bien choisi lui-même.
Plutôt le grand vase.
Il aurait été normal
qu'il refuse.
Mais Urhu était trop gourmand.
Un phénomène n'a pas pu
être anticipé.
Cochons, bovins et ovins sont,
a l'état sauvage,
porteurs de maladies.
L'élevage a créé les conditions
pour qu'ils nous les transmettent.
Au début, personne n'a fait
le rapprochement, pas même Urhu.
La rougeole, la tuberculose,
la grippe, la petite vérole,
tous ces fléaux nous seront
transmis par notre bétail.
Ma mère s'en allait. Son corps
n'était plus que souffrance.
Son agonie semblait atroce,
et nous étions impuissants.
incantations.
- Les coutumes funéraires
ont changé.
On garde le corps des défunts
dans la maison familiale,
signe d'une plus grande importance
donnée à la lignée.
Toute la famille doit donner
au mort, y compris Urhu.
incantations.
un.
- Idru, notre sorcier, intercède
auprès des divinités.
Il facilite le passage
dans l'autre monde.
On dit qu'il peut parler
avec les morts
et ceux qui les accueillent.
En quelques jours,
ce fut une hécatombe.
Toute la famille du potier
est morte. Et d'autres.
Et encore d'autres.
Des familles entières.
Et bientôt,
il n'y avait plus personne
dans la maison pour les enterrer.
Les sages ont décidé
de les mettre dans une fosse,
hors du village,
pour chasser les odeurs.
Le conseil siégeait
depuis la veille,
mais personne, même le chaman
ne trouvait d'explication au mal.
Comment aurait-il pu savoir?
Le seul indice était
les rougeurs.
Le mal commençait
par des plaques rouges.
"Montrez vos corps.
"Nous verrons si le mauvais sort
vous a désignés.
"Montrez !
"Le mal invisible qui rôde
choisit ses complices.
"Ils ne peuvent nous échapper,
"car la trace du Vilain
est sous leurs habits."
Ceux qui avaient ces traces
étaient maudits.
Urhu avait trouvé le signe du mal
et on voyait
qu'il avait raison.
Urhu s'est imposé comme le seul
capable d'arrêter le fléau.
Il fallait écouter ses paroles
et obéir à ses ordres.
C'était une malédiction.
Ceux qui portaient la marque
devait quitter le village.
Même son frère devait partir.
Ils ne comprennent pas
le rôle des microbes.
Face a ces catastrophes,
ils accusent |es forces invisibles.
Urhu vient d'inventer
un nouveau pouvoir:
celui du chef.
Urhu est devenu l'homme
le plus important du village.
Celui qui décide seul
pour tous les autres.
Il devenait l'unique héritier
de la lignée de Gaya.
Qui mieux qu'Idru pouvait dire
combien le chef voyait juste ?
Il fallait chasser le mal !
Le chef savait où était le mal.
Très vite, le religieux devient
le premier soutien du politique.
On est partis, une dizaine,
sans savoir ni où
ni comment
on allait survivre.
"Le feu éloigne
les mauvais esprits."
Sans le savoir, Urhu a pris là
une mesure salutaire :
éliminer le mal par la chaleur.
On brûlera les bêtes mortes.
Cette mesure a arrêté
l'hécatombe chez les animaux.
"Merci, Urhu, de la lignée de Gaya.
Merci
"pour ta clairvoyance.
Merci de nous sauver."
Enfin ils reconnaissaient
son pouvoir, son intelligence,
sa justesse.
La chasse aux complices du mal
a continué.
Urhu a vite compris
qu'il lui fallait une force armée
pour l'aider.
Les maisons étaient fouillées,
les êtres vivants, contrôlés.
Ceux qui portaient la marque
étaient bannis,
et leurs biens étaient marqués
à la chaux.
Quand un chef prend
de bonnes décisions,
ceux qui en bénéficient
le remercient par des présents.
Urhu devient plus riche
et on lui manifeste du respect.
Son orgueil allait
le faire basculer.
Notre groupe errait sans but.
Les nôtres mouraient
les uns après les autres.
Les épidémies ont
des caractéristiques.
Elles se propagent vite
d'une personne à une autre.
Et ce sont des maladies aiguës:
ou l'on meurt,
ou on se remet
dans un court laps de temps.
Peu à peu,
le mal quittait nos corps.
Nous étions sauvés.
Les plaques rouges avaient disparu.
Seuls trois d'entre nous
avaient survécu.
Il crie.
Après des semaines de marche,
nous avons trouvé la vie.
Mais qui étaient ces gens ?
Ces gens venaient d'Anatolie,
du nord.
Eux aussi avaient connu |a maladie.
Beaucoup d'hommes avaient disparu.
Ces femmes sans hommes
nous ont bien accueillis.
Dans notre village,
les hommes commandaient,
et les femmes décidaient
à la maison.
Chez ces étrangers,
une femme prenait les décisions.
C'était nouveau.
Hennissement d'un cheval.
- D'Anatolie, ces femmes
avaient apporté
2 découvertes majeures.
Le cheval.
Cet animal fougueux, farouche
et indomptable était la,
devant mes yeux,
docile et calme
tel un agneau de lait.
Elles ne l'avaient pas apprivoisé
pour sa viande.
Kelee...
Cette femme me donnait le vertige.
Elle suscitait en moi
un sentiment inconnu.
Envie de chanter, de danser,
de |a serrer dans mes bras,
envie de prendre sa bouche
et d'y coller la mienne.
La 2e découverte allait changer
la vie
de mon père et des hommes.
Quel était ce métal ?
Il était très dur.
Mon père n'avait jamais vu ça.
Comment l'avaient-ils fait ?
Mon père voulait savoir,
mais le secret était bien gardé.
Chez nous,
l'épidémie s'était arrêtée,
et Urhu en avait bénéficié.
Les biens des bannis
étaient sous sa responsabilité,
dont ceux de son frère.
Mais à qui servaient-ils,
dans ces maisons vides ?
Urhu eut l'idée de récupérer
la récompense faite par mon père.
Celui-là et celui-ci.
Tout compte fait,
c'est ce vase qu'il voulait.
Les biens des maisons vides
furent réquisitionnés.
Urhu dit qu'ils appartenaient
a |a communauté.
Rapidement,
ils vont devenir sa propriété.
"Tout cela pour lui tout seul ?"
Non.
Cela ne plaisait pas a Idru.
Le chaman devait être un allié.
Sa fidélité serait récompensée.
Le chef distribuera des richesses
a ses partisans.
Il créera une élite,
une classe sociale
au-dessus des autres.
Le bronze.
Ce métal prodigieux.
Le forgeron voulait garder
le secret, mais la femme tatouée
avait le pouvoir et
une grande tendresse pour mon père.
Du cuivre...
de l'étain...
mélangés dans un même bain.
C'était simple,
mais il fallait avoir eu l'idée.
Le bronze permet de faire
des outils plus performants.
Il va accroître
la productivité agricoles.
Il permet aussi de façonner
des armes bien plus résistantes.
Qui avait eu cette idée ?
Combien d'essais,
avant que ce mélange
ne soit trouvé ?
L'histoire de Kelee était dessinée
sur son visage.
Je découvrais une femme
sensuelle, fière
et qui avait de la nature un don.
Celui de susciter
l'amour des autres.
Tous ceux qu'elle regardait
étaient conquis.
Moi, j'étais vaincu.
J'avais presque oublié le passé
et toutes nos douleurs.
Au village, tout avait changé.
Le pouvoir avait déformé Urhu.
Son statut exigeait qu'il loge
dans l'ancienne maison communale.
Il avait ordonné qu'on mette
partout des statues de Gaya.
Il n'était plus comme les autres.
Il ne travaillait plus aux champs.
Son rôle ne lui permettait plus
de s'abaisser a ces tâches.
Il devait donc être entretenu
par ceux qu'il dirigeait.
Chacun dut apporter
sa contribution.
Une sorte d'impôt.
Ça ne plaira pas a tous.
On finira tous par l'accepter.
Une organisation
du pouvoir est née:
la chefferie.
Urhu est entretenu par tous,
une part du fruit du travail
lui est remise,
il en fait profiter
sa classe dirigeante.
S'installe alors une hiérarchie,
des convoitises
et une lutte pour le pouvoir.
Kelee avait changé ma vie.
L'amour avait fait de moi un homme
et j'avais trouvé un sens
à cette existence chaotique.
Elle m'avait fait découvrir
la vitesse, la fougue
et l'ardeur du cheval au galop.
Cet animal va transformer
notre perception des distances.
Mais personne n'a encore essayé
de le monter.
Il faudra attendre 2 000 ans
avant d'inventer l'équitation.
Guéris et forts
de ce que nous avions appris,
nous avons décidé
de retourner chez nous.
C'est là que je suis né. C'est là
que mon père est né. C'est là
que je veux vivre avec toi.
Le mécontentement grondait
dans la population.
Urhu était devenu un despote et
ne tolérait aucune contradiction.
Urhu et Idru n'avaient pas prévu
notre retour.
Mon père était l'aîné
de la lignée de Gaya.
Il voulut savoir quels présents
son frère lui rapportait.
"Des pierres ?" Était-ce là
l'honneur qu'on lui faisait ?
Et les richesses ? Comment
comptions-nous le récompenser
pour son génie sans limites ?
Un enfant parle.
Le pouvoir appelle le pouvoir,
posséder appelle plus de richesse,
et tout cela perturbe l'esprit.
Idru se rendait compte
que son chef allait trop loin.
que l'équilibre entre son apport
et son coût est rompu,
Mais que pouvait il faire ?
Il a pris ma raison de vivre,
mais la force est avec moi.
Le bronze me rendrait Kelee.
celui-ci est condamné.
Quand un seul a le pouvoir
de décision
et qu'il n'entend plus
les cris de ses semblables,
celui-ci est condamné.
Urhu était allé trop loin.
Urhu était condamné.
un.
- Perdu, Urhu était prêt à tout
faire basculer plutôt que de céder.
un.
Bruit d'un couteau
planté dans la chair.
- Idru, le chaman, avait trahi.
Le goût de la propriété,
le plaisir du pouvoir,
la peur de le perdre,
ont forgé la vanité de l'homme.
Et sa vanité
est son propre bûcher.
Mon père décida
que je devais régner.
C'était à moi de guider mon peuple
dans le monde qui s'annonçait.
Kelee et moi essayerons
d'en être dignes.
Les chefferies vont devenir
des royaumes.
Le pouvoir du monarque éclairé
repose sur la prospérité du peuple.
Il faut redistribuer la richesse,
au lieu de |'accaparer.
Mais pour en avoir plus
sans la prendre aux siens,
il faut aller en chercher ailleurs.
Ainsi seront inventées les guerres.
Dans les 2 000 ans qui vont suivre,
de grandes cités vont voir le jour.
En Asie, au Moyen-Orient,
en Méditerranée, en Amérique.
Les agglomérations voudront
s'agrandir.
Elles vont lever les 1res armées,
prendre des villages, les fédérer.
Ainsi naissent |es premières cités.
La 1re va fleurir
dans l'actuel Irak
et donner naissance
à la grande civilisation sumérienne.
Nous sommes en 2 500
avant Jésus-Christ, en Mésopotamie.
Je suis Tobar, le berger,
de la lignée de Gaya.
Depuis mon enfance,
j'ai rêvé de voir la grande cité.
Qui a pu construire
de si grands bâtiments ?
Était-ce là
l'œuvre des dieux ?
Les cités vont exercer
une fascination immense.
Pour la 1re fois, des populations
d'origines différentes,
de langues différentes
construisent ensemble.
Il y a des esclaves,
des marchands itinérants,
des artisans, des paysans
venus échanger leurs récoltes,
leurs animaux.
Où allaient tous ces gens ?
Quel but poursuivaient-ils ?
Certains se croisaient
sans se regarder.
Je n'avais jamais vu
autant de tout.
Des objets venant
de contrées lointaines :
bijoux, parfums, épices,
alcools...
Certains étaient
uniquement pour le plaisir.
Le plaisir des yeux, du nez,
de la bouche,
le plaisir d'entendre.
Musique.
un.
- Que font-elles ? On ne
faisait pas ça, au village.
Des métiers ont été inventés.
Tout ici a une valeur,
tout se marchande,
se négocie.
Il y a aussi partout
la présence de l'état.
Le roi a maintenant
de nombreux représentants,
dont ceux qui sont chargés
de prélever l'impôt,
essentiel à la vie de la cité.
Le scribe est responsable
des comptes,
mais le chef des gardes fait
exécuter les décisions du Trésor.
un.
- Certains minimisent leur fortune
pour diminuer leur contribution
à l'Etat.
Pour comptabiliser les impôts,
on a inventé un système
de codes gravés dans l'argile.
L'écriture est née, mais ne sert
qu'à enregistrer |es transactions.
J'étais fasciné par ce scribe.
Sarki maîtrisait les signes.
C'était pour moi un savoir magique.
Pouvait-il compter les étoiles ?
La dette du tisserand envers l'Etat
avait triplé.
Il lui était impossible de payer.
Sarki et lui étaient amis,
et il s'est porté à son secours.
Pourquoi lui demander autant
tout de suite ?
Il pouvait régler
en plusieurs fois.
Le chef
se souvenait de tout.
Rien n'arrêtait sa détermination.
Le chef des gardes servait le roi
avec zèle,
mais il usait de son autorité
pour assouvir sa cruauté.
"Vous servez le roi, en le privant
de ses meilleurs artisans ?"
Plus Sarki défendait le tisserand,
plus le chef le corrigeait.
Le palais du roi !
Le centre de la fourmilière
était une maison
plus grande que la plus grande
dune du désert.
Les impôts y étaient acheminés.
Je voulais voir derrière ces murs.
Mais c'était un quartier interdit.
J'ignorais que ça existait,
un lieu où seuls certains peuvent
entrer. Je n'avais jamais vu ça.
Sarki rendait ses comptes
au trésorier,
qui faisait un état des richesses
et estimait |es besoins.
Il n'avait pas intérêt
a se tromper, sa vie en dépendait.
L'impôt était alors échangé
avec les grands marchands.
Le trésor du roi était converti
en lingots d'argent.
Ces plaques deviendraient plus tard
ce qu'on appellerait |a monnaie.
Je voulais voir
derrière ces murs.
Pourquoi cachaient-ils
leurs activités au peuple ?
Dans mon village, on pouvait voir
facilement le chef.
C'était comme un village doré,
à l'intérieur de la cité.
Ici se prenaient les décisions.
Tout y semblait merveilleux.
Il y avait : architectes,
artistes, savants...
La plus grande concentration
de connaissances.
Les richesses servent
à entretenir la cité,
mais aussi à la protection
du royaume.
Des pillards nomades avaient fait
incursion au nord.
Le roi voulait lever
d'autres armées,
et fabriquer de nouvelles armes.
Il avait besoin de plus!
Ce scribe m'attirait.
Je voulais le rencontrer
et surtout apprendre.
Son savoir me fascinait.
Je savais maintenant
pourquoi j'étais venu.
Je voulais écrire.
Je vous en prie,
enseignez- moi !
"Écrire n'est pas une possibilité
ouverte à tous. Cet art
"est réservé à une élite,
petit berger."
Grâce à l'écriture,
les rois étendent leur pouvoir
jusque dans des contrées éloignées.
Mais leurs messages
doivent rester secrets.
Personne ne doit les déchiffrer.
D'où l'importance stratégique
de |a connaissance des signes.
En m'initiant,
Sarki prenait un risque énorme.
Il n'avait pas le droit
de m'enseigner ce code secret.
"Regarde et tais toi."
Sarki m'avait pris
en affection
Je crois qu'il aimait ma jeunesse,
ma naïveté et mon regard.
"L'écriture demande de la rigueur.
"Mais n'apprends jamais
sans comprendre.
"Regarde.
Le principe est tout simple.
"Un signe sur l'argile.
Et tu choisis ce qu'il veut dire."
La lignée de Gaya est ancienne,
et j'ignore d'où on vient.
Si mes ancêtres avaient pu
écrire.
J'avais raté ma première leçon,
mais mon échec avait donné
une idée à Sarki.
Une idée qui pourrait sauver
le tisserand.
Il devait contribuer à l'effort
supplémentaire de guerre.
Le chef des gardes était prêt
à le dépouiller.
La sophistication
de l'organisation de |a cité
apporte aussi
son lot d'injustices.
Les fonctionnaires exécutent
des ordres
sans tenir compte
de la réalité de la vie chacun.
Cette fois, les efforts demandés
pesaient trop lourds.
Le tisserand avait caché
ses dernières réserves.
Après 20 ans de loyauté,
Sarki était prêt à trahir son roi.
Il était révolté contre les abus
et prêt à mentir
pour sauver son ami.
Les scribes vont bientôt
faire mieux que recopier.
Ils vont inventer des symboles
pour représenter des idées,
des mots.
Je comprenais
que l'écriture pouvait devenir
un outil plus puissant.
Elle permettait de représenter
un savoir, de la science,
et de les diffuser
à un plus grand nombre.
Mais elle pouvait aussi mentir
et tendre des pièges.
C'était une arme redoutable.
Pour réparer l'injustice
faite à son ami,
Sarki avait falsifié
la demande du Trésor royal.
Quelques signes modifiés,
et la somme était différente.
Le trésorier était tendu,
n'arrivant pas
à réunir tous les biens exigés
par le roi.
Sarki trahissait pour la 1re fois.
Il avait peur.
La faux était bien fait,
mais le trésorier avait un doute.
Le chef des gardes avait tout vu.
Il savait
que la preuve du méfait était
sur une plaquette,
mais il ne savait pas laquelle.
Sarki me traitait durement.
Je ne sortais pas,
j'avais peu a manger,
je ne pouvais pas dormir
plus de 4 heures par nuit.
Plus j'apprenais vite,
plus Sarki augmentait ses exigences.
Parfois,
je regrettais mes moutons.
Tiens, mais...
comment écrit-on le mot mouton ?
un.
Sarki avait fait l'objet
d'une enquête.
On avait retrouvé
la plaquette falsifiée
et on l'avait comparée
à l'original.
un.
"Que feras-tu de ton savoir?
"A quoi va-t-il te servir?"
"A voyager, petit chef."
"Tu es perdu.
"Tu seras exécuté."
Sarki alla en prison.
Lugal, le chef des geôles,
était connu dans |a cité
pour sa force et sa cruauté.
La prison. Quelle drôle d'idée ?
Au village, celui qui était puni
était surveillé par les autres.
Tout le monde le dévisageait
et sa honte le punissait.
- Sarki...
- Être privé de liberté
est un châtiment terrible.
Pour un berger inculte comme moi,
c'eût été la mort.
Bruits.
- Les nourritures intellectuelles
aident à supporter...
la solitude, l'ennui,
les persécutions.
Un des autres avantages
de l'écriture
est qu'elle transmet le savoir
à un grand nombre.
Encore faut-il
qu'elle soit enseignée.
Sarki avait décidé d'instruire
les prisonniers, même le muet.
Sarki n'avait pas le droit,
mais il s'en moquait.
Il voulait partager son savoir.
Transmettre ses connaissances
avant d'être condamné a mort.
Cela fut possible,
car Lugal voulait apprendre.
Il fut autorisé à écouter
et à regarder.
Il n'en dit rien
à ses supérieurs.
L'écriture aura du mal
a se démocratiser. Il faudra
des millénaires.
Mais on sait que la prospérité
d'une cité est liée
à l'instruction de son peuple.
Ne l'ayant pas compris,
les rois ont voulu garder
le savoir
pour mieux l'instrumentaliser.
Sarki avait trahi son roi.
Pour les grandes affaires,
le seul juge est le roi.
Sarki serait puni de mort.
Les hommes mettront longtemps
à séparer la justice et le pouvoir.
Les exécutions publiques offrent
un spectacle divertissant,
mais surtout, elles renforcent
la suprématie du souverain.
Je ne pouvais pas laisser faire ça.
Sarki m'avait tout appris
et avait risqué sa vie pour moi.
Je devais
risquer la mienne pour lui.
un.
Lugal était fier
de ce qu'il avait appris.
Il aimait s'en vanter.
Je l'aimais, et j'ai compris
compris qu'il m'aimait aussi.
J'étais son disciple, son protégé.
Il m'avait mis dans son cœur.
Tiens. Le symbole de Gaya.
Elle te protégera.
un.
En vivant dans les cités,
l'homme s'est affranchi
des dangers de la nature.
Il n'en souffre plus,
mais il ne les connaît plus.
Il trouve son chemin
en lisant dans les étoiles,
mais ne sait plus trouver l'eau.
Sans ombre pour le protéger,
son corps l'abandonne.
Sarki sentait sa fin approcher,
mais il ne regrettait rien.
Il préférait mourir libre
que vivre dans le mensonge.
un.
Les gens du désert sont habitués
à trouver des citadins perdus.
En général, c'est trop tard,
ils sont morts de soif.
Qu'allaient-ils faire
d'un mourant?
Le dépouiller
et l'abandonner aux vautours ?
un.
Qui étaient ces gens ?
Pourquoi l'avaient-ils sauvé?
Ils étaient nomades, et pour eux,
l'étranger est un voyageur
à qui l'on doit l'hospitalité.
Ils étaient de la lignée de Aar.
Une famille ancienne
qui ne s'était jamais convertie
à la vie sédentaire.
Ils connaissaient
la lignée de Gaya, très bien.
J'ai continué à étudier, seul,
sans jamais oublier Sarki.
Grâce à son enseignement,
je suis devenu un lettré.
Mais le maître me manquait
toujours.
Il m'avait tout donné, à moi,
le petit berger.
Sarki s'était trouvé une vocation,
transmettre son savoir.
Il se vengeait du pouvoir abusif
des rois,
et surtout, il éclairait
le chemin des simples.
Entre les grands centres urbains,
de nouveaux nomades sont apparus.
Organisés en caravanes,
ils sillonnent |a planète,
échangent des biens
et organisent inconsciemment
la grande diffusion du savoir
qui ne cessera d'augmenter.
Grâce à eux et au pouvoir
d'attraction des cités,
les savoirs vont se cumuler.
Les sciences, les arts,
les techniques vont progresser.
Grâce à Sarki, ils ont maîtrisé
les chiffres et les symboles.
La connaissance de l'écrit
affranchira les peuples
du pouvoir exclusif des rois.
Dix ans avaient passé.
Sarki retrouvait la ville
qu'il avait fuie.
un.
J'étais devenu un scribe royal
et un maître.
Sarki n'en croyait pas ses yeux.
Il était fier de moi.
Sarki avait parlé de moi
aux nomades.
Il voulait que je vienne.
Il voulait me faire découvrir le
monde, ses richesses et ses peines.
Je suis resté,
car ma place désormais était ici,
au milieu de mes disciples.
L'écriture avait besoin de moi.
Je ne comptais plus
les trésors du roi. J'écrivais
la grande histoire des hommes.
J'écrirai l'histoire
de la lignée de Gaya,
pour qu'elle soit lue
aux confins du monde
pendant des milliers d'années.
L'écriture va devenir le pilier
de la création humaine,
le plus puissant moyen
de communication de l'univers.
Les hommes seront des milliards
et communiqueront leur savoir
de plus en plus rapidement.
Et quand il ne sauront plus
où aller,
ils regarderont derrière,
pour savoir d'où ils viennent.